For every forgettable blockbuster that has
come and gone, there's been a steady stream
of stellar under-the-radar action flicks.
What they lack in terms of scale and big-budget
effects, they make up for with their share
of bone-shattering brawls, white knuckle chases,
and bloody bombast.
A few years back, writer/director Ted Geoghegan
made a name for himself among the genre set
with the atmospheric haunted house film We
Are Still Here.
Though the film's no-budget production limited
what Geoghegan could ultimately accomplish,
there was enough style on display to get excited
about what the filmmaker would do next.
Surprisingly, instead of horror, Geoghegan
jumped to gory action in Mohawk.
Mohawk unfolds in the last days of the War
of 1812, and finds a young Mohawk woman and
her lovers squaring off against a violent
band of American soldiers.
Mohawk might flag a bit in dialogue-heavy
scenes, but when Geoghegan leaves words out
of the mix, this underseen actioner has as
much energy and vision as any blockbuster.
If you've got an Amazon Prime subscription,
then you're probably aware of the streaming
service's new action series Hanna.
What you might not be aware of is that the
show is based on a 2011 film of the same name.
That film ended up doing moderately well at
the global box office, but it feels like it's
been all but forgotten by audiences in the
years since.
Like the series, the film version of Hanna
follows a teenage girl who has a penchant
for putting down bad guys with a graceful
brutality.
All the while, she's hunted by a secretive
intelligence operative a mirthfully menacing
Cate Blanchett.
Hanna is a taut, boldly stylized pseudo-detective
action fantasy that delivers a weighty payload
in terms of both pulse-pounding set pieces
and character driven drama.
It's high time this action-packed gem got
rediscovered.
"I just missed your heart."
For many American moviegoers, exposure to
the work of Japanese extreme auteur Takashi
Miike begins and ends with his dark 1999 masterwork
Audition.
Understandable as it may be, you're doing
yourself a disservice by ignoring his other
films.
Among Miike's sprawling output, you'll find
the work of a visionary filmmaker with a flair
for genre, a penchant for gore, and plenty
of eye-popping action.
You'll get plenty of all of that in Miike's
2010 samurai stunner 13 Assassins.
Set in the waning days of Feudal Japan, the
film's setup promises a harrowing showdown
between the title assassins and the shogun's
ruthless brother, whose upcoming promotion
threatens to bring chaos to the otherwise
peaceful Japanese landscape.
Miike takes his time getting to that showdown,
meticulously building toward the fateful finale
with a screenplay that allows audiences to
get good and comfy with the anti-heroes and
villains of the piece.
When Miike finally blows the lid off 13 Assassins,
he does so with a bloody, brutal savagery
all but unseen in American cinema.
Wheelman follows a freshly paroled getaway
driver played by Frank Grillo who finds himself
double-crossed and on the run.
Fittingly for a movie following a character
played by long-time character actor Grillo,
the film is very much the sort of pulpy crime
flick that plays to his strengths.
Writer/director Jeremy Rush gives his star
ample room to talk tough, act tough, and drive
hard.
Rush amplifies the film's inherent machismo
by keeping his camera confined almost entirely
within a single car.
It's a bold, stylish move that pays off in
spades, giving a fresh perspective to the
sort of car-crashing, fist fighting, and machine
gunning we've seen a million times over.
"What's your name, man?"
"I don't wanna talk."
"What?"
"Chitchat.
I don't chitchat unless it's about the job."
One day, the world at large will catch up
to the genius of writer/director Joe Cornish.
When it does, they'll likely look back on
2011's Attack The Block and wonder how it
ever became a box office bomb.
Cornish's film delivers the action-packed
stoner comedy/alien invasion/horror flick
the world never knew it needed.
Sadly, the world still seems oblivious to
this sharply written, exquisitely executed
genre mashup, despite the jaw-dropping action
scenes and killer creature design.
Not to mention what should have been star-making
turns from future Doctor Who star Jodie Whitaker,
and later Star Wars star John Boyega.
Do yourself a favor and check out this hidden
gem.
Though the bloodshed has finally stopped,
the simmering tensions that drove Irish Catholics
and Protestants headlong into the carnage
of "The Troubles" remains a part of life in
Northern Ireland.
In Belfast circa 1971, the setting of '71,
the divisive fires that drove the madness
still burned with the raging heat of bombed
out cars and gunpowder.
'71 opens with a kindly new recruit joining
a British military regiment in the war-torn
streets of Belfast.
The film pivots sharply when an angry mob
ends up separating the man from his retreating
regiment, leaving him lost, alone, and injured
in a situation where he's perceived as enemy
to one and all.
From there, the film plunges viewers into
a breathless, nightlong race for survival
through an unforgiving landscape where vengeance
is righteous no matter the cost.
'71 is that rarest of action films that dares
to examine both the human cost of the bloody
conflict and the cycle of hate that fueled
it.
"You should be ashamed of yourselves!
These boys are young enough to be your sons!"
In case you missed out on Haywire in theaters,
the film follows a tough-as-nails black ops
agent called Mallory who finds herself hunted
by international mercenaries after being double-crossed
on a clandestine mission.
With plenty of grit, brawn, and brains, Mallory
quickly turns the tides on her betrayers,
setting up a hunted-becomes-the-hunter revenge
tale for the ages.
Though Haywire marked director Steven Soderbergh's
first full-blown action flick, you'd never
be able to tell by how effortlessly he executes
the film's intricate set pieces.
Each escalating act comes with a style and
whimsy most action movies never even aspire
to.
That Soderbergh cast legit MMA star Gina Carano
in the lead role only serves to legitimize
each vicious escalation even as the film unapologetically
begins to earn its title.
It all makes Haywire an overlooked diamond
among Soderbergh's impeccable filmography.
If you'd have told us a few years back that
we'd be listing a certified fresh, Tom Cruise-fronted
sci-fi epic among our "underrated action movies"
picks, we probably would've told you you were
completely insane.
Yet here we are, half a decade after its release,
still wondering how so many people slept on
this intelligent, action-packed banger.
Edge of Tomorrow, which follows a soldier
continuously killed during a deadly alien
assault only to be dropped right back into
the action, is worth remembering.
This Groundhog Day-esque action film is a
classic, one that matches epic human drama
against an equally epic scope.
It's also a film with an insanely cool sci-fi
concept with mind boggling special effects
and set pieces that make repeat viewings endlessly
rewarding.
If you haven't seen it, go watch it.
If you have seen it, see it again.
“I would go with the sense of manifest destiny,
the ranks, the rags to riches rapid rise through
the ranks a born to deliver us...
The people… well they love that sort of
thing."
Few genres are as well primed to build big
time action into a narrative as science fiction.
While Hollywood has given us its share of
supersized sci-fi bombast over the years,
audiences have proven themselves equally open
to experiencing more concept-driven science
fiction fare.
While Leigh Whannell's clever, camp-tinged
techno thriller Upgrade sits firmly in the
latter category, this unpredictable tale wholly
embraces its big-budget ambition.
It's the sort of savvy, small-scale science
fiction that deserved a much broader audience.
If you're among those who missed Upgrade in
theaters, it follows a technophobic everyman
who blazes a path of bloody vengeance after
a mugging leaves him paralyzed and his wife
dead.
He's aided in that endeavor by STEM, a computer
chips that allows him to walk, as well as
dole out plenty of violence on his attackers.
From start to finish, Whannell spins a wholly
original, action-packed sci-fi tale from clear
influences, all while having way more fun
with its haughty-yet-silly concept than most
action movies would dare.
"You are now in full control, Grey."
Let's take a moment to talk about Jeremy Saulnier's
harrowing survival drama Green Room, a film
that couldn't find its audience even with
a glowing review from Quentin Tarantino.
Oddly, that may simply be the result of one
too many people pegging Saulnier's punk-tinged
chiller as a horror film.
While the story itself is endlessly horrific,
Green Room might've found its audience if
viewers had been expecting a first-rate action
flick instead.
That's not to say there aren't ghouls aplenty
in Green Room.
There are.
They just happen to be of the very human Neo-Nazi
persuasion.
Their prey, a down-on-their-luck hardcore
band, are equally human.
When they inadvertently witness a murder while
on tour, the band's instinct is to hightail
it out of town.
Their Nazi counterparts have other plans,
which gets even worse when their sneering
leader shows up and essentially condemns the
band to death.
From that moment on, Green Room breathlessly
propels itself forward with the filth and
the fury of a punk rock thrasher, indulging
in unflinchingly tense showdowns and grueling
acts of violence every step of the way.
Saulnier delivers an insightful, surprisingly
timely action thriller that'll leave your
brain racing and your heart pumping overtime.
In case you hadn't noticed, Netflix has been
churning out movies at a feverish rate over
the past several years.
Of course, with their under-the-radar release
strategy and general lack of proper promotion,
it's entirely likely you've missed out on
more of those releases than you thought.
We'd lay even odds that the blisteringly brutal
gangster drama The Night Comes For Us is among
the films you missed.
If that's the case, it's an oversight that
action fans will want to rectify immediately,
because this blood-soaked crime saga packs
a punch you won't be able to shake.
At the center of that saga is a former Triad
enforcer named Ito who, while slaughtering
an entire village for his bosses, stays the
execution of a young girl.
In doing so, he sets off a bloody chain of
events that puts the Triad on their trail.
Matters get insanely violent from that moment
on, with a ceaseless wave of Triad henchman
armed with cool names, cool weapons, and cooler
than cool attitudes taking on Ito and a few
loyal members of his old crew.
Bones are broken.
Limbs are severed.
Bodies are set aflame or blown to bits.
Through all the grueling, meticulously orchestrated
action, the film also manages to capture a
deeply human story of redemption.
For action fans of a certain age, the late
'80s remain a fertile time period for a particular
sort of absurdly predictable and way over
the top action flick.
There's no doubt that genre maven Adam Wingard
is one of those fans, and his stylized, horror-tinged
thriller The Guest is all the proof you'll
ever need.
For the uninitiated, being predictable and
over-the-top aren't really hindrances to this
sort of film.
In fact, the mixture of seriousness and absurdity
is all part of the fun.
Wingard and screenwriter Simon Barrett have
about as much fun with that approach in The
Guest as any filmmakers have ever had.
Leading the charge for the film's giddily
over-the-top vibe is Dan Stevens, who delivers
a fascinatingly unhinged performance as a
mysterious soldier who befriends an unsuspecting
family.
He's ostensibly there to pay respects to their
son, who supposedly died in combat while serving
alongside Stevens' character.
Without spoiling any of the dizzying madness,
we'll just say that the man isn't who he claims
to be.
As bodies start piling up around town, The
Guest twists and turns from eerie stolen identity
drama into a surreal, neo-noir horror show
rife with all the genre affectations one could
ever hope for.
"You want the elite?"
"I'll take all of them.
“All the handguns?”
No everything.
All your guns."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.